♪ ♪
>> WELCOME BACK TO THIS SPECIAL
EDITION OF "HANNITY."
CRIME CONTINUES TO RISE IN
AMERICA'S DEMOCRAT RUN CITIES.
A NEW YORK CITY NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR WAS ARRESTED FOR ROBBING A
CHASE BANK.
IT CAME ONE DAY AFTER HE WAS
REPORTEDLY RELEASED FROM POLICE
CUSTODY AFTER THE PROSECUTOR'S
REQUEST FOR ROBBING A DIFFERENT
CHASE BANK.
DURING THE NEAR ACCIDENT MAYORAL
DEBATE, ONE CANDIDATE REFUSED TO
ANSWER WHEN ASKED ABOUT TAKING
GUNS AWAY FROM NEW YORK CITY
POLICE OFFICERS.
THE BACKLASH WAS SO STRONG THAT
HER TEAM IS NOW DENYING SHE
WANTS TO DISARM THE COPS.
AT ME WELL, AS IT SHOULD IN THE
CONTINUE TO SOAR IN NEW YORK
CITY, FORMER NYPD POLICE CHIEF
TERRY MONAHAN SAYS IT WAS A
MISTAKE TO DISBAND THE END TYPE
CRIME UNIT WITHOUT REPLACEMENT.
THE UNIT WAS DISBANDED LAST JUNE
AMID WIDESPREAD VIOLENCE AGAINST
POLICE.
AND RIOTS INCLUDEING --
INCLUDING JULY 15th INCIDENT.
GOOD EVENING.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> GOOD EVENING, JUDGE.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> GOOD.
ALL RIGHT.
WHEN WE STARTED WITH -- I'M
TERRIFIC.
THANKS.
WE STARTED WITH ONE GUY WHO IS
BEING RELEASED AFTER HAVING
ROBBED A CHASE BANK.
WHILE HE IS OUT ON NO BAIL, HE
BROUGHT ANOTHER CHASE BANK AT
THAN HE IS RELEASED AGAIN.
WHEN YOU WERE CHIEF OF THE
DEPARTMENT, LIFE WAS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT AND THE CRIMINALS KIND
OF GOT, YOU KNOW, THEY GOT A
LITTLE MORE SERIOUS IN TERMS OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND HOW THEY
WERE BEING HANDLED.
>> THAT IS A DIRECT RESPONSE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT
INDIVIDUAL, YOU ARE A JUDGE.
IF YOU HAVE DISCRETION AND THIS
MAN JUST ROBBED A BANK AND YOU
WERE TOLD HE WAS HOMELESS, YOU
WOULD NEVER HAVE LET HIM WALK
BACK OUT ON THE STREET.
UNDER BAIL REFORM, IT IS
MANDATORY.
THAT ON A ROBBERY LIKE THAT, YOU
HAVE TO GET AN AUTOMATIC RRR, NO
MATTER HOW DANGEROUS YOU ARE BUT
THE ONE THING WE HAVE ALWAYS
ASKED, WE ARE NOT LOOKING TO GO
TO THE SAME THING WE HAD BEFORE.
BUT WE ELECT JUDGES, PEOPLE THAT
WE ELECT, APPOINT JUDGES, GIVE
THEM THAT DISCUSSION.
IF SOMEONE IS DANGEROUS TO THE
COMMUNITY, THAT INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD NOT BE PUT BACK OUT ON
THE STREETS.
>> Jeanine: AND, YOU KNOW, THE
OTHER PART OF IT IS, IF YOU GOT
THIS GUY WHO JUMPS OR IS ABLE TO
LEAVE ON ONE ARREST OR HE
COMMITS ANOTHER ROBBERY OF A
BANK WHAT MAKES THEM THINK THIS
GUY IS GOING TO SHOW UP FOR
TRIAL ANYWAY?
YOU AND I BOTH KNOW HE IS NOT
GOING TO SHOW UP FOR TRIAL
UNLESS HE IS BROUGHT IN ON THE
DAY OF TRIAL.
AND THE CHANCES OF THAT
HAPPENING IS SLIM TO NONE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS MAYA
WILEY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF HER?
>> LISTEN, HER STATEMENT, THE
IDEA OF DISARMING COPS IS THE
MOST RIDICULOUS THING I HAVE
HEARD IN MY LIFE.
WE HAD TO SENATE -- 700 PEOPLE
SHOT IN THE CITY SO FAR THIS
YEAR.
EVER GREAT COPS IN NEW YORK CITY
MADE OVER 1300 GUN ARRESTS.
HOW YOU MAKE THAT CAN REST IF
YOU DON'T HAVE A GUN ON YOUR
SIDE?
IT WOULD JUST LEAVE US WITH THAT
COPS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
>> Jeanine: IT IS AMAZING
BECAUSE WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN THE
PROBLEMS WITH THE FUNDING
POLICE.
THIS MOMENT THAT YOU ARE SEEING
ON THE SCREEN IS RUNNING FOR
MAYOR OF NEWARK CITY.
SHE WANTS TO TAKE ANOTHER
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE NYPD.
THIS IS CRAZY TOWN NOW.
I'M GOING TO -- WE ONLY HAVE
ABOUT TEN SECONDS.
BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK?
CAN NEW YORK COME BACK FROM
THIS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND WE ARE COMING BACK.
WE HAVE THE GREATEST COPS IN THE
WORLD.
YES, YOU CAN.
WE HAVE THE GREATEST COPS IN THE
WORL